I'm Laura Ingram and this is the Ingram
angle from Washington tonight
run Joe run that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
all right after millions of illegal
aliens stop calling them migrants by the
way have rushed into our country
siphoning off our Public Services Joe
Biden was shamed into making a quick
border trip to El Paso now the tour was
highly choreographed and generally
meaningless kind of a soviet-style
propaganda coup to show our dear leader
in the best possible light
and here you have Joe Biden going right
there to the border to see what's going
on so I give him a lot of credit for
that visiting the border and making sure
that conservatives in those areas know
that he really is listening to their
concerns about border security he does
seem to be working directly on his prop
directly on this issue and he's very
aware of what's going on in the Border
coming down and seeing it with his own
eyes really made a big difference and
made a big difference
who would eat with these clowns but he
did do a heck of a job chatting up
Salvation Army volunteers
or wait a second were they from the
Secret Service same difference
okay
now if you're a Democrat and you're
still waving off concerns about Joe's
age and declining cognition then you're
just in denial or maybe you know that
although Biden is one fall away from the
senior center lunchroom he's still the
sharpest knife in the Democrat drawer
it's certainly not this woman
who stood Like a Star Wars Century
behind Biden at that immigration speech
last week
and it definitely definitely is not
mayor Pete
starring in his own transportation
sitcom known as leave it to Buddha judge
so the dot aware of Southwest Airlines
Antiquated system for scheduling prior
to Christmas I don't run Southwest
Airlines
you said back on The Late Show that you
were confident that they'd be ready to
service the tickets that they're selling
and the airlines have made major
improvements largely because we press
them to do that
the bottom line is Biden's visit to the
Border was all theatrics no substance
now we threw a few bones to the
enforcement crowd but they do little to
change the math
we are getting overrun
there were over 73 000 gotaways in
November the highest number on record
November also saw the highest number of
encounters at the border over 233
000 and the total number of
apprehensions and gotaways for 2022
surpassed
3.3 million that's another record
but don't let these numbers make you
fret because team Biden wants you to
know they mean business now my
Administration is taking several steps
to stiffen enforcement for those who try
to come without a legal right to stay
we're focused on cracking down on drug
smuggling which is a serious and deadly
promise oh excuse me problem we are
doing everything that we can to secure
the Border and to deal with irregular
migration that is a priority for this
Administration since day one
a regular migration
now that reminds me of when they told us
that inflation was a transitory it's all
happy talk no actual facts to back any
of it up
you're to ask no questions by the way
just believe the empty promises
[Music]
[Applause]
president Camacho stood before the world
and promised everyone that Joe would
solve all their problems
would not only end the Dust Bowl and
heal the economy but he would cure acne
and car sickness as well
now remember Joe promises that soon
you'll see and feel all the magic of his
runaway spending by the way agreed to by
key Senate Republicans
Biden's saying patience people
I know it's going to take time to
implement our entire economic agenda
which we already passed and for folks to
field it in their day-to-day lives but I
think folks are going to see it in the
next few months as tough as these times
have been if we look a little closer we
see bright spots all across the country
we're surely making progress things are
getting better
progress is that what he's calling it
well you be the judge here are some
headlines
Americans retirement accounts are drying
up as they're forced to dig into their
Savings in 401ks to pay the bills
and what about Americans who have no
retirement accounts or regular savings
well they're paying more than 19
interest rates because they're maxing
out on their credit cards
and if progress is measured in layoffs
Biden's doing a bang-up job at Goldman
Sachs it's a massive bloodbath they're
calling it where they're going to start
axing 3200 on Wednesday and at
Salesforce 8 000 staff will be shown the
door at Amazon more than eighteen
thousand
and remember big Tech and the big Banks
all wanted Biden well they got by
Dynamics didn't they
and now that he's destroyed the economy
Biden is the Democrats obvious 2024
choice
after bowing down to The Fringe
greeniacs and the pro-trans radicals the
Biden team is already trying a phony
pivot to the middle
and this pivotal performance art was
made possible in part by none other than
Mitch McConnell it's not just this
project but the infrastructure Bill the
bipartisan infrastructure bill that the
president signed
provides dramatic additional assistance
where eight billion dollars over the
next five years
bring home the bacon
but Real Americans are not impressed and
they don't want McConnell's friend to
run again
no I don't think Biden should run again
he's too old and he's lost it and people
have really lost respect for him I'm not
sure he's going to be up for it
physically or quite quite frankly
cognitively his approval rates are not
good at all they're
Ferry down and I think that our country
needs someone who unites all of us
wait a second is she actually saying
that Biden in his kooky cabinet haven't
United America well
it might be hard to unite us I'm just
kind of thinking this through when they
paint half the country as white
supremacists and America as systemically
racist
they try to act like they're still so
devastated about January 6th but the
truth is the Democrats have an intimate
relationship with the Insurrection
narrative
they're in love with the video and the
photos of the chaos
it's sick frankly
so by all means run Joe run but no
basement campaigning this time no
debates hosted by rank partisans no
domination of early voting no hiding
from skyrocketing fentanyl deaths and no
sidestepping questions about hunter's
gravy train in China and his mystery art
buyers and certainly no avoiding
responsibility for inflation and a
pessimistic Nation
you're going to own all of it and that's
the angle hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else